also jetzt geht es wieder etwas
vollkommen anderes es geht auch nicht
einmal also nicht direkt über
schülerlabore sondern eigentlich geht's
über außerschulische lernorte so lernt
man das nennt man das in der schule habe
ich ausgemacht vermittelt ich auch nicht
konzentriert außerschulische lernorte
also was sind außerschulische lernorte
alles das es einfach alles wo
schulklassen irgendwohin gehen also
außerschulisch und was lernen
naja man also wenn sie ins hinzugehen
den sender gehen und sich irgendwas
angucken wenn sie an die uni kommen
schülerlabore ist natürlich auch so eine
sache
wer hat schon mal was mit schulklassen
gemacht mit der hand hoch okay das war
in welchem zusammenhang der foto ag und
das war in welchem zusammenhang mit
diesem punkt
da war die schulklasse das war so nicht
außerschulisch und wir waren also eure
erfahrungen heterogen bei einem vortrag
ok irgendwie den deine schuld und unter
angebote
ja also ich hab ich bin also
molekulargenetiker und also ich hab ich
hab so schülerlabore habe ich eigentlich
schon so ziemlich von anfang an seit ich
an der uni bin habe ich gemacht
zum einen deswegen weil ich mal
ausprobieren wollte weil ich das spaß
fand hauptsächlich aber auch als ich
wieder münchen zurückkommen weil die
ganzen lärm studierenden die mit mir
ausgebildet wurden meine ganzen freunde
sind natürlich alle hier geblieben
die haben dann gehört ich bin wieder da
oder haben sie gesagt auch kann man mal
kommen mit unserer schulklassen
also habe ich schon relativ lange solche
schülerlabore gemacht ja und das war
eben ich würde sagen eine heterogene
erfahrung die ich da gemacht hat damit
er also macht immer spaß mit den
schulklassen aber es gibt es gab immer
die gleichen probleme und zwar erstens
mal mehr gut zum vortrag zu halten
es geht es noch relativ einfach ein
schülerlabor ist halt immer einen tag
aufbauen dass die schulklassen dann also
ich drei vier fünf sechs stunden was
machen aber wieder ein tag abbauen
beziehungsweise auf hat der zweite ist
ich war vollkommen eigentlich abhängig
von der lehrkraft wie gut haben die das
vorbereitet und ich glaube die
heterogenität die die man da trifft das
hat einfach zu tun mit der lehrkraft
also sagen die kündigen die das an als
etwas das ist supertoll wir sind ja an
der universität das erlebte einmal im
leben außer ihr studiert hinterher
das ist jetzt fast alles oder abzusagen
also nächsten freitag übrigens der gema
an die universität und was mir dann auch
passiert ist dass die dann halt gesagt
haben er hat übrigens ich muss jetzt
damit ahgz weg da kommt dann aber eine
kollegin die springt dann also weiter
und dann wo man merkt auch da ist
eigentlich gar nicht
und ist nichts vorbereitet und sagen
natürlich dumm und das dritte was mich
daran was ich sehr unbefriedigend fand
dass er ich habe keinerlei ahnung ob das
was ich da jetzt vermittelt ob das
irgendwie auch ein lernerfolg bringt
also es gibt so viel literatur zur
außerschulischen lernorten und ich
glaube was gesichert ist als erfolg von
außerschulischen lernorten ist motiviert
schüler und schülerinnen und schüler
wenn die mal mit so was zusammenkommen
dann kommen sie halt auf die idee ich
will jetzt astronaut werden ich will
physiker werden ja ich will orgelbauer
werden ich will ihm zu arbeiten sonst
wirkt also partiell werden die motiviert
aber was den lerneffekt angeht da ist
natürlich auch ein bisschen schwierig
dann zu messen aber da gibt es also sehr
heterogene bis nicht aussagekräftige
literatur ich bin jetzt kein die
daktiker ich darf das sagen weil ich
weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht aufwendig
vielleicht doch was gibt gut also dass
war das war für mich so ein bisschen was
das unbefriedigende dran ist und also in
dem zusammenhang
es ist für mich vor allem deswegen
unbefriedigend weil ich hab sonne also
wenn wir mal so wenn ich meine lehre
philosophie also was für mich so das
zentrale ist von dem wendig lehre machen
wenn ich das mal darstelle also ich habe
drei zentrale punkte die ich über die
jahre jetzt herausgearbeitet hat für
mich und das ist für mich ist das
essentielle die motivation aller
beteiligten also sowohl bei einer
studierenden oder jetzt in dem fall
werden dass die schüler aber auch meine
eigene motivation dann das alles was ich
machen möchte
nachhaltig ist ja deswegen das leben so
frustrierend wenn ich nicht weiß was
hinten herauskommt
und für mich ist ein ganz ganz wichtiger
aspekt auch die reflektion dass alle
beteiligten eigentlich über ihre rolle
sich auch reflektieren da drin also
wissen was passiert jetzt eigentlich
gerade und das ist meiner ansicht nach
auch für die
nachhaltigkeit ist es sehr wichtig und
wenn man das jetzt praktisch umsetzt da
gibt es für mich drei zentrale elemente
die ich versuche in lehrveranstaltungen
immer rein zu bringen das ist die
relevanz was ich vermittle muss relevant
seien für die beteiligten
naja das ist also klar studierenden
zentriert die vertiefung in
verschiedenen ebenen für die
nachhaltigkeit und vor allem wichtig
dass ganz wichtiger aspekt in jeder
lehrveranstaltung ist immer das feedback
für mich aber auch das feedback für die
beteiligten für die reflexion
doch das ist jetzt mein ding hier das
sind für mich die maxime jetzt ist nur
die frage was hat das jetzt eigentlich
alles zu tun mit studierenden
zentrierter leere wenn ich von
außerschulischen lernorten spreche na ja
nicht einmal gedacht ist zwar
frustrierend aber vielleicht kann ich
doch auch in zukunft wieder
schülerlaboren so organisieren dass mir
spaß macht und dass diese sachen
umgesetzt werden und vor allem ist
natürlich auch eine sache daher bislang
war alles was ich gemacht hat das war
immer so vielleicht
öffentlichkeitsarbeit
ich habe immer darauf dass es niemand
mitbekommt dass ich das mache weil ich
muss ja auch das geld und sonst eigene
das rechtfertigen und da ist mir die
idee gekommen
naja die schüler warum muss ja
eigentlich nicht ich betreuen kann da
jetzt studierende betreuen
damit haben eine lehrveranstaltung damit
haben wir eine rechtfertigung als wolle
man das ganze in umsetzen da und da ist
eben dieses konzept habe ich mir
ausgedacht das integrierte schülerlabors
also dass der zentrale punkt ist wir
haben jetzt hier zwei bereiche
wir haben zum einen haben wir die
universität wir haben hier die schule
und wir haben jetzt also wenn jetzt in
der molekularbiologie bleiben haben wir
eben ein praktikum das an der
universität stattfindet und das kann
jetzt aber auch irgendwas ganz anderes
sein
ein schreibwerkstatt eine sonst
irgendwas mit und ich möchte jetzt dass
erstens dass das ganze relevant ist und
ich möchte auch dass die teilnehmer
jetzt kommen von der schule und das die
gut vorbereitet sind um die
nachhaltigkeit zu machen und das geht
natürlich am allerbesten
wenn es eine vorherige schulstunde gibt
die direkt darauf vorbereitet
und wiederum dafür brauche es eine
fachliche vorbereitung in der schule und
das geht natürlich nur in dem moment in
dem das jetzt ein thema ist was auch
wirklich relevant ist was im lehrplan
drin ist und diese schulstunde die
werden natürlich nicht ich machen
sondern in dem fall wenn das eine
lehrveranstaltung ist habe ich hier
studierende die ich ihm fachlich und
didaktisch vorbereitet die dann eher
hingehen dann kommen die studierenden
zurück werden hier betreut
und um das ganze zu vertiefen und auch
um die reflexion zu bringen haben wir
nach geordnet dann noch zwei
veranstaltungen also hier in der schule
eine nachbesprechung des ganzen bzw
kann das auch durchaus daneben was sich
neckt schulaufgabe sonst irgendetwas zu
diesem thema sein
und natürlich eine nachbereitung der
universität so das ist das konzept und
ganz generell s concept ich sage jetzt
mal wie ich das jetzt umgesetzt habe für
diesen bereich den wo ich mich auskenne
und zwar also ich habe hier circa zehn
studierende
ich habe circa zehn schulklassen pro
einmal im jahr mache ich das im sommer
diese zehn studierenden die breite ich
fordere die bereiten sich eigentlich ihr
von vier seminartagen und einen
praktikumstag erkläre ich gleich noch
was man da machen und in dem fall sind
das elfte klasse oder jahrgangsstufe 11
in der biologie und die machen in diesem
jahr machen sie ihm genetik und da passt
ein thema hat ganz hervorragend rein und
zwar der genetische fingerabdruck
das ist nämlich im lehrplan drinnen das
ist etwas was im wunderschönen praktisch
machen kann und vor allem was in der
schule nicht praktisch durchgeführt
werden kann ein operativ eignet sich als
er fort solange dafür da ein praktikum
zu machen
und ja und die nachbereitung die schaut
eben so aus dass wir hier nochmal zwei
seminartagen hinten dran
1 für feedback für die veranstaltung die
studierenden gemacht haben einst
generell für über die lehrveranstaltung
und hier ist noch mal eine
nachgearbeitet schulstunde mit
nachbesprechungen und evaluation
so etwas wollen wir hier jetzt um die
lehrveranstaltung anzuschauen diese vier
seminarstunden das erste ist rein
organisatorisch das zweite die zweite
stunde da geht es nur darum dass ich
fachlich das abklären studieren damit
die auch wissen worum geht's hier
eigentlich sind lehramtsstudierende die
kennen nicht alle die haben das alle von
mir gelernt entweder vor einem halben
vor eineinhalb vor zweieinhalb vor
dreieinhalb jahren die gehen davon aus
dass wir das können und eigentlich ist
meine aufgabe nur in dieser stimme an
dieser stelle ihnen zu zeigen
das glaubt dir aber da sind noch lücken
und die zeige ich euch jetzt mal weil es
natürlich verstanden haben müssen uns
weiter zu gehen und das würde ich sagen
das ist so meine input einheit ja da
also da wird halt fachlich abgefragt und
das ist für die jungen ganz großes
erlebnis
ich habe auch durchaus diesen diese
sache her genommen diesen teil weil das
ist fachlich schwierig das ist wirklich
so die die krone dessen was man in der
elften klasse analytisch weitergeben
muss schon ziemlich auch verstehen das
ganze und dann sind zwei weitere
seminartag und diese seminar tage da ist
der input von mir relativ minimal da
geht es nämlich einen ersten seminartag
darum was wollen wir überhaupt
vermitteln also was sind so die großen
bereiche also ich habe ich hier schon
gesagt wir haben hier
polymerase-kettenreaktion gilt
elektrophorese genetischer fingerabdruck
usw und in gruppen erarbeiten die dann
eben jetzt in diesem fall hier dass wir
jetzt mal für die pcr in gruppen
erarbeiten die das ist die theorie
dahinter beziehungsweise was ist hier
die praxis wir
sie formulieren dann lehramt studieren
das sind ja immer sehr gut eben die
lernziele und da sind ja voll mit dabei
war nämlich später als lehrkräfte müssen
das natürlich genau so machen
da geht es um die tausend sachen und das
haben wir dann für den gesamten bereich
können dann auch aufteilen was ist wird
besser in der schulstunde vermittelt was
ist besser vermittelt in praktikum und
anschließend wissen dann die meisten
studierenden eben was in der schule
vermittelt wird die haben schon
frühzeitig kontakt mit den lehrkräften
aufgenommen und sprechen damit den
lehrkräften auf was sie was sie in der
schule machen und der arbeiten zusammen
mit denen der lärm studierenden heißt es
artikulation schemata die bekomme ich
dann und dann machen wir in der vierten
seminar stunde manchmal so ein blind
review also jeder kriegt artikulation
schemata von jemand anderem
und dann wird das untereinander
besprochen und das ist eben auch also
dass wir jetzt hier so ein artikulation
schema passt ihm durchschauen und wo sie
sagen das sind jetzt so sehr kleinen das
ganze ist es auch nicht so wichtig also
sich begrüßung einstieg dann haben sie
hier so leitfrage 123 ja also wie kann
man ihn aus zellen isolieren die
funktioniert die pcr wie kann ich die
immer sichtbar machen für analysen
nutzen oder sowas immer eine
doppelstunde und da geben die sich
gegenseitig daneben feedback
das sind alles material wie natürlich
relevant sind weil die müssen ja
hinterher auch diese zustände irgendwann
mal halten
das tolle daran ist das ist eine der
lehrveranstaltung wo ich niemals
schieben muss weil am ende steht der
ihre performance also das ist ja
wirklich eine schulstunde
und da kommt eine schulklasse und die
mir sind das praktikum betreuen und das
ist unglaublich angenehm weil das ist
genau das was man als lehrer haben
möchte dass man begleiter ist dass sie
sagen oh ja wie mache ich das wie mache
ich das versuchen dass man rat geben
kann
das fragen kommen anstatt dass man sagen
muss auch und da muss doch daran denken
da was zu überdenken
ja und dann machen wir nochmal gemeinsam
eben einen praktikumstag also an diesen
praktikumstag spielen die das praktisch
einmal durch und dann sehen sie auch
wieder ablauf ist wir können auch mal
fragen klären und dann geht's los
und das ist jetzt also hier so ein foto
das ist aus dem allerersten jahr damals
waren sie jetzt in dem fall
drei studierende die zusammen zwei
schulklassen betreut haben
mittlerweile ist es sogar so dass die
meisten studieren denn die ich habe
sagen die machen das alleine und die
jetzt also hier vorbereiten der
vorbereitenden schulstunde das haben sie
in dem fall jetzt in gruppenarbeit
gemacht das überlasse ich denen
vollkommen beziehungsweise in absprache
mit der lehrkraft ja und dann kommen
dass es idealerweise ist es ein paar
tage bevor sie eben in das praktikum com
und das ist diese dieser schöne ping
pong effekt
die kennen sich jetzt die waren bei uns
so und jetzt kommen wir zu denen dann
kommen die eben alle in das labor
kriegen ihre kittel angezogen und dann
schaut das ganze so aus also das ist
dann recht intensiv betreut also es ist
auch so dass die studierenden nicht nur
ihre klasse betreuen sondern auch noch
weil jemand anderem sozusagen als als
kurs helfer damit arbeiten
die können auch als studentische
hilfskraft dann auch gleich noch mehr
betreuen sitzt doch immer noch mal
jemand drin der hospitiert in diesem
fall weil es ein schülerlabore ist ist
es so ich muss da immer dabei sitzen ist
natürlich ein großer zeitaufwand macht
aber auch spaß das ganze wir jetzt nicht
der fall wenn zum beispiel die lehrkraft
dann wenn man da was er sich was man
besuchten museum oder so was muss ich
muss dich jetzt als lehrkraft nicht
unbedingt dabei sein
das habe ich mir ausgesucht dieses thema
genetischer fingerabdruck bei
molekulargenetik ist wirklich etwas
enorm abstraktes gerade für schüler in
den schülerinnen in der alterstufe weil
was man praktisch macht ist ja man hat
praktisch farblose flüssigkeiten die man
mit anderen farblosen flüssigkeiten dann
zusammen tut ja und da ist jetzt die in
a drinnen forscher aus den tropfen
wasser und damit das irgendwie sichtbar
gemacht das heißt das ist sehr
anspruchsvoll aber das war also deswegen
habe ich das auch herausgenommen um die
studierenden da eben auch ein bisschen
zu fahren
bei dem ganzen okay so und anschließend
gibt es eben auf der seite der
lehrkräfte oder der schulen gibt es dann
noch mal so eine evaluation hinten dran
also da habe ich dann auch noch mal
drucken da habe ich auch noch mal einen
evaluations proben wo eben dann die
schüler dann das ganze bewerten können
und auf der seite der studierenden ist
ebenso wir treffen uns noch zwei mal wo
das erste mal geht es ihr um so ein
erfahrungsaustausch
was die also was etwas bei ihnen gut
gelaufen ist was sie gelernt haben auch
vor allem wo sie bei anderen hospitiert
haben und das zweite treffen da geht es
dann
für mich für die lehrveranstaltung was
könnte man da mal verändern das könnte
man da verbessern bei denen schulklassen
jetzt geht es mit lernerfolg ja ja keine
ahnung
ja ich bin jetzt kein die daktiker es
gibt keine begleitforschung dazu wir
bekommen natürlich super feedback das
macht den spaß aber es geht ja in
stockum seien die sonne wirklich etwas
lernen
ich bekomme von den lehrkräften feedback
darüber in welchen bereichen sie den
eindruck haben dass die studierenden die
schüler und schülerinnen was gelernt
haben und was wieder vergessen haben
dazu kommen ein gewisses feedback aber
natürlich jetzt nicht ob es besser ist
oder schlechter ist weil sie den schüler
der bau gemacht haben und besser ist und
schlechter ist weil eine vorbereitende
schulstunde da ist keine ahnung
das einzige wo ich sagen kann also das
ist wirklich was sehr sehr positive
erfolg der bezieht sich jetzt auf die
studierenden
und da ist es so dass erstaunlicherweise
eine sache immer wieder herausgehoben
wird von studierenden als das was ihnen
am allermeisten gebracht hat ich hätte
jetzt immer so gedacht banal gesagt am
allermeisten wird ihnen der praxisbezug
was bringen
ganz ehrlich die studierenden die zu mir
kommen
die sind eigentlich alle schon also ich
arbeite da eigentlich mit der creme de
la creme das sind alles die die wollen
das machen die haben das auch schon voll
gemacht die können das auch den kann man
auch ein bisschen helfen aber die sind
ja schon voll dabei also die sagen dann
nicht jetzt habe ich da mal praktisch
was gemacht soll ich sagen es war toll
dass ich mal wieder so was gemacht habe
und es ist auch toll dass ich mal ein
schülerlabor gemacht habe
das ganz entscheidende für die ist das
feedback was sie bekommen
das war für mich verwirrend weil ich
gedacht haben das muss eigentlich in so
einem lehramtsstudium müssen ja nicht
dauernd feedback darüber kriegen was sie
machen ist aber so anscheinend nicht der
fall und das besondere an dieser
veranstaltung ist allerdings auch sie
bekommen jetzt hier wirklich ein 360
grad feedback ja das bedeutet die
studierende studierenden bekommen
natürlich feedback von der lehrkraft
weil die sitzt drinnen ja und die sagt
denen die wahrheit die schulstunde
gleichzeitig sitzen auch die mit
studierenden drinnen also die sind immer
mal so eine stunde sind die da können
sich auswählen und geben denen auch
feedback darüber auch die die als
betreuer mit dabei sind sagen dann
natürlich auch mal wow das war eine
super idee oder da wusstest du jetzt
aber auch nicht weiter was also ich
jetzt vielleicht suchen so gemacht
ich setz rennen geht ihnen feedback und
dann etwas was sie sehr sehr selten
bekommen sie bekommen die evolution
durch die schülerinnen und schüler das
wird als das wertvollste bei ihnen
angesehen dass sie ebenso ein sehr
vielfältiges feedback bekommen und weiß
nicht ob das jetzt zu änderungen bei
denen führt aber immerhin
also das ist das was ich als ergebnis
sagen kann
so und jetzt als dozent was ist jetzt
für mich so der out kam also was man
damit die relevanz ansieht relevanz ist
glaube ich gegeben bei dem ganzen
es ist hier ist es im lehrplan drinnen
ist es etwas was die studierenden
hinterher machen
das wurde nie in frage gestellt also bei
den studierenden kommt auch als
rückmeldung mehr dabei sind sinnloses
dabei das kommt mir immer alles brauchen
die vertiefung ist gegeben
ich weiß nicht ob es was bringt am ende
aber sicher besser als ohne und feedback
wurde eben angesprochen bei den
studierenden das wird das sehr positiv
herausgestellt
und wenn ich mir das jetzt anschaue was
den aufwand angeht
naja schauen wir einfach mal also jetzt
noch mal die zahlen bis einschließlich
sommer 2018 also das ganze läuft jetzt
seit sommer 2013 sei es schon ein
bisschen länger dieses konzept gut da
hatten wir jetzt 59 studierende das ist
jetzt nichts besonderes ist das was man
an lehrveranstaltungen hat aber da haben
wir natürlich jetzt 53 schulklassen
gehabt in dem ganzen und fast 1000
schülerinnen und schüler das ist ein
multiplikator ischer wert den man
einfach hat zwar als ein einzelner
dozent wenn man sieht ich glaube da ganz
schön viel angekommen
das motiviert natürlich auch ja und also
wenn ich jetzt so ist euch sagen was
sind so die erfahrungen die ich da
gemacht habe es nie lernen dass das
nicht rede ist was sind was sind meine
erfahrungen davon und dankeschön
also erstens organisatorisch ist das
ganze durchaus herausfordernd
ja wenn man zehn schulklassen hat und
zehn studierende oder so was das ganze
zu machen das ist eine herausforderung
und da muss man sich das gut überlegen
wie man das macht kommunikation mit
lehrkräften ist schwierig ja zum
beispiel wenn man ein osterferien hat
dann ist ganz klar das ab freitag vorher
bis montagmittag danach her ist einfach
die existieren sie einfach nicht wie man
sich drauf einstellen das geht schon man
muss lange im voraus muss man das ganze
plane
es gibt keinerlei probleme meiner
erfahrung nach lehrkräfte zu finden die
so was machen wollen das angebot ist
vergleichsweise sehr dünn
wer immer so was machen will es ist
überhaupt kein problem die zu finden
also
einfachste ansprechpartner sind
natürlich immer die didaktik lehrstühle
in den jeweiligen bereichen die lärms
studierende machen die kennen leute für
den anfang und wenn sich das
rumgesprochen hat also ich mache jetzt
gerade die anmeldungen also 2021 sind
noch plätze frei
das geht total einfach man kann viel
bewirken schwierig was man allerdings
machen muss also man ist natürlich immer
noch ausgeliefert
wie gut sind die lehrkräfte da ist meine
erfahrung
je besser man vorher kommuniziert und
das ist in dem fall haben so eine
informationsbroschüre die ich den
lehrkräften vorher schicke wo also ganz
genau drin entsteht an welchen punkten
was von ihnen erwartet wird als zum
beispiel organisationen der
vorbereitenden schulstunde das steht
dann drinnen
erstens terminabsprache für die konzept
besprechung zweitens vor wissens ist
kurses muster studierende bekommen
und drittens kursstruktur informationen
zu besonderheiten
ja das können wir als also kriegen sie
beide können dann ab gehen unterstützung
bei der vorbereitung des unterrichts
feedback zur schulstunde organisation
des praktikums tags und solche sache
also es ist hier genau vorgeschrieben
und das hat sich sehr gut herausgestellt
es gibt immer menschen die lesen und
nicht lesen
es gibt immer lehrkräfte die ich
jederzeit wieder neu aufnehmen und
andere wo ich sage jetzt darf man jemand
anders ran
da hat man dann schon kennen
und ansonsten weitere probleme die ich
durchaus habe bei diesem bei diesem
konzept
ich habe durchaus schwierigkeiten lernt
studierende zu finden wieder mitmachen
also ich könnte immer mehr nehmen als
sich anmelden
da guckt man jetzt ist klar zwei die
dies mit machen die sagen das ist das
super das klasse das erzähle ich allen
ja die teams müssen mitmachen super
tolle sache was auch immer ja nach
meinen erfahrungen sind
lehramtsstudierende enorm effizient in
aufwands optimierung und das ist
durchaus etwas ich weiß nicht womit das
zu tun hat weil das studium so voll ist
mit allem möglichen man muss schauen
worauf man sich bezieht aber es ist
durchaus etwas wo ich ihm feststelle
naja man gut das sind jetzt drei cds
punkte was kann man da alternativ machen
wie groß ist der aufwand und der aufwand
ist hier natürlich größer das heißt es
lohnt sich nur für jemanden der sich
wirklich dafür begeistert deswegen sage
ich das ist also luxus na ich arbeite
wirklich mit tollen studierenden
zusammen
die mir auch wieder sehr viel bringen
also wo ich drin sitzen mir denken so
kommen auch unterrichten also sechs
semester die einfach perfekte stunden
machen können
die immer aufmerksam sind alles also wo
ich mir denn geworden wo ist nur das
gelernte na super
am anfang hatte ich so gedacht als das
entworfene das ist ein super reality
check für studierende die lange nix zu
tun menschen klassement schau diesen
effekt kann man vergessen ich habe
keinen einzigen studierenden jemals
gehabt wo ich sagen würde
hast du gemerkt dass das nicht sein ding
ist überhaupt nicht also das ist
durchaus dass wir in diesem fall ist es
hier ein problem was ich da habe
und deswegen bin ich von diesem konzept
sehr überzeugt und bin froh wenn ich
jemandem mal jedem erzählen kann der
nicht bei drei auf dem baum ist weil das
eigentlich das ist was man sehr leicht
anwenden kann in allen möglichen
bereichen wo man eben lernen studierende
hat und wo das ganze rein passt
danke